he took office during a global pandemic
and made battling covid19
his top priority promising 100 million
vaccines would be
administered by april we met that goal
last week by day 58
42 days ahead of schedule now today i'm
setting the second goal
and that is we will by my 100th day in
office
have administered 200 million shots
in people's arms that goal was exceeded
this week now more than 230 million
vaccines have been given out
with more than half of all americans
receiving at least
one dose what we're seeing is a
president who continues to be
disciplined
continues to stay on message and also a
president who continues to
focus on the issues and i think that's
what many americans
like to hear from their politicians
biden promised to ease
economic pain from the pandemic as well
delivering on a campaign promise to get
direct payments to millions of people
who were out of work
it not only addresses the immediate
crisis we're in it's better for the
long-term
economic health of our nation and our
competitiveness
by the end of march millions of
americans had received at least fourteen
hundred dollars
or more to help pay expenses like rent
and food
in his first 100 days biden also kept
another campaign pledge
rejoining the paris agreement on climate
change
that limits greenhouse gas emissions his
predecessor donald trump had pulled the
u.s
out biden rejoined the u.s on day one
to voters of color biden also delivered
on addressing systemic racism
in policing after the conviction of
derek shovin the police officer who
murdered george floyd
biden's justice department announced a
federal investigation
into the minneapolis police department
where chauvin was employed
and while biden did follow through on
his pledge to raise the minimum wage to
15 dollars an hour for federal
contractors
his plan to push for a federal minimum
wage
for everyone has faltered
his next goal to fix america's
infrastructure and create jobs
could be one of his most ambitious tasks
the theme of this first 100 days
could be characterized by terms such as
bold
daring and adventurous
biden repeatedly promises to meet the
moment
building back better from the covid
crisis channeling
a spirit not seen since president
roosevelt's new deal in the 1930s
building schools roads and parks and
lifting millions of americans wages
and quality of life following the great
depression
in that spirit president biden has
already expanded
america's social safety net and he's
promising more
biden's betting that americans are
looking for solutions to problems
like race and income inequality that he
believes
only government can deliver kimberly
hellcat al jazeera
washington